Hi everyone.
It is great to
see you all virtually again for this
well third lecture out of the lectures
that I'm giving inside this geometric
deep learning lecture series.
And
for today's lecture, we are going to
actually try to somewhat escape the
realm of what you have been doing over
the previous lectures which dealt with
group theory and representation theory
and how those areas of
of mathematics can be used to re-derive
and rediscover
many of the influential
deep learning architectures that we use
today and also how to categorize and
organize the plentiful research of deep
learning that
that we're bombarded with every day.
However,
there are actually some potentially
limiting or restrictive factors with
using group theory to um
to model architectural design. And
therefore, especially as we start to
model some more expressive or more
exotic architectures, it might be
interesting to also keep in mind what
lies beyond the realm of groups. So,
this is what this lecture is all about.
We'll be going beyond groups and into
the realm of categories.
And I just like to say before kicking
off this lecture
that I'd like a great thanks to Taco who
has uh kind of almost co-developed these
slides together with me in terms of in
terms of content. Both of us are uh
quite actively working on the research
that you will hear about
in this lecture. So, definitely, if you
have any follow-up questions, please
don't hesitate to ask either me or Taco.
We would be very happy to discuss these
things. So,
uh just as a brief recap of what you've
seen in previous lectures. So, you've
seen how we can take this
idea of geometric deep learning which
arises from invariance and equivariance
and related locality ideas. And as a
result of just directly applying the
ideas in the blueprint, we have been
able to re-derive and rediscover several
popular architectures.
I've shown you how to reason about deep
sets, graph neural networks, and
transformers in my lecture series. Uh
there have been several related lectures
afterwards that introduced you to some
of the other models you see on this
slide, like ComNets, group equivariant
ComNets, spherical models that work over
over the sphere, and also various kinds
of mesh CNNs.
And this is the table that we've shown
several times during this course that
shows how you can re-derive each one of
these popular architectures or even more
infamous architectures like the
spherical CNN by more or less directly
applying the ideas from the geometric
blueprint, so selecting a domain your
data lives on and the symmetry group you
want to be resistant to. And this is
just a kind of color code what you've
seen as a function of which lectures
you've seen it in. So, lecture five,
lecture six, we've covered graph related
neural networks and then going beyond
that
is what you saw from lecture seven to
10. Now, in the previous iteration of
this course which you might come across
online,
we have actually
also had a lecture on sequence models
and LSTMs. However, for this year we
have decided to
leave the exposition of LSTMs to the
proto book if you are interested to
learn more about it. And instead, we
thought it would be more interesting
just thinking of the current you know
emerging movements in the field, it
would be more interesting to show you
what lies beyond groups which maybe
we collectively haven't understood as
well
this time last year. So, we think now
it's a good time to also give you some
insight on what lies beyond. And if you
would like to learn more about LSTMs,
you have last year's lecture and you
have the book as well.
You will not get anything LSTM related
on the exam for sure.
So,
so that we can start talking about going
beyond groups, it might be good to kind
of just do a first step recap on what
the essence behind everything that we've
been doing so far is and undisputedly
those would be the symmetries. So, here
you have the familiar example of all the
symmetries of a triangle that would be
generated by
rotations and horizontal flips. And if
you remember, a symmetry is a
transformation of an object that leaves
that object unchanged for all intents
and purposes. So, here if you rotate and
flip the triangle, it is technically
still the same triangle. You're just
changing where all the three nodes of
the triangle are, but from this
perspective, we assume it's actually the
same triangle just observed differently.
And we want to then potentially build
neural network architectures over this
triangle such that these constraints are
respected.
And based on the idea of symmetry and
this idea of resistance, we then were
able to design one at a time neural
networks that were fully resistant to
these kinds of symmetry transformations.
So,
the two main concepts were invariance
and equivariance
where invariant models were built such
that applying any symmetry on the input
does not change the output. This is
perfect if you want to have predictions
on the level of the entire domain. And
then equivariance predictions which
boils down to having
symmetries on the input which then will
affect the output, but they'll affect
the output in a very predictable way.
And it turned out that these concepts
were pretty much sufficient to re-derive
all the fan favorite architectures. So,
that's already a good sign that just
focusing on group theory and symmetries
is a good idea for studying deep
learning. But what we want to talk about
today is are these symmetries actually
the whole story? And to kind of ground
ourselves mathematically in in this
question, I'm going to just quickly
recall the axioms of symmetry groups.
So, this is a slide that you've seen
before, I believe in one of Taco's
lectures, which shows you what are all
the things that a group has to satisfy.
So, you have just as a recap, a group is
a set this capital G we typically use
for it. And the elements of G can
compose with one another using this
binary operation GH. And then that
operation has to satisfy certain
properties like the composition must be
associative, there must exist an
identity, for every transformation there
must exist an inverse, and also
as you repeatedly apply
pairs of elements, you can always
compose them to obtain a new element in
the symmetry group. And here on the
right-hand side uh one of my personal
favorites, the rotational symmetries of
the Rubik's Cube.
And if you look at these definitions,
you can see that there are already some
things that are quite strong about
assuming a symmetry group. And
specifically, I've highlighted two of
them. We might also want to consider
more aspects of it, but the two that are
particularly prudent are this assumption
that every
transformation must have an inverse.
This basically means that all the
transformations you care about are never
going to lose information.
And the second property, which is this
idea that no matter which two
transformations I take, I can always
make a composition of them, which subtly
makes the assumption that all of my
symmetry transformations must compose
with each other.
And
strictly speaking, in reality, this is
often not the case that all of your
transformations will be invertible. So,
it is possible that you might care about
operations that will lose some
information about your about your data.
And the previously studied blueprint
will just not work in those cases
because it assumes that your data lives
in a symmetry group, in which case the
transformations must be invertible.
Um
further, as I said, we are assuming that
we can take pairs of transformations and
always compose them. Well, in reality,
not all pairs of transformations are
going to be composable for many
realistic scenarios.
So, as a result,
we might be interested in going beyond
the realm of what
symmetry groups can explain. Now, one
thing I want to highlight, and this is
very important especially for the recent
lines of research on very large models,
is that when you have access to big
quantities of data, you don't have to be
as rigorous about this in the sense of
you can either take a close enough
symmetry group to approximate these
transformations or you can use just
straight-up data augmentation and make
the network learn to be resistant to
these kinds of transformations. But this
is beyond the scope of what we want to
do in this course because we're
interested in how to take rigorous
constraints of uh neural network
architectures respecting certain
properties and then actually enforcing
those constraints into the architecture,
right? So, everything that deals with
approximative or augmented approaches to
enforcing symmetries is technically
outside of the direct scope of this
course because um effectively, it talks
about pushing the network in a direction
of doing something, but the network is
under no
reason necessarily obliged to respect
that property, especially when going
beyond the training set.
Now, since it seems that at least two
fundamental properties of groups, such
as invertibility or composability,
are potentially not going to be
satisfied, it seems like we need
something a bit more general than group
theory. And specifically, we might need
a perspective to allow us to reason
about general computation, which might
be lossless and which might not
necessarily compose.
And what I hope to convey to you during
the course of our lecture today
is that category theory is a dynamic
field of mathematics that might offer us
such a perspective. I hope
I hope you will enjoy this
I hope you'll enjoy this exposition. And
uh
once again, I encourage you if something
sounds unclear during the course of this
exposition, please feel free to ask
questions either in the Zoom chat or in
Campuswire.
So,
Peter, there's a question. Mhm. Okay.
Cool. Someone is asking, "Please, a
group is a set of what?
Functions or"
That's a that's a good question.
Um in the case of what we've been
studying in this course, a group will be
a set of functions. But in reality,
uh there are no constraints on what the
things inside the group are. We just
talk about them as group elements and
and some binary operation, such as
composition. But for the purpose of this
course, I think you can almost always
safely think of them as functions.
Yeah.
Um okay. So, now what we're going to see
is how we are going to transition from
the world of group theory into the realm
categorical, into the domain of category
theory.
And what basically is going to happen,
just to give you kind of a heads-up and
a blueprint of what's going to happen
throughout this lecture, we are
gradually going to take the concepts we
used in group theory, such as groups,
group representations, and then finally
the the gold star equivariance, from
which we derive our architectures.
And we will generalize all of them in a
categorical framework. So, groups are
going to become categories,
representations are going to become
functors, and equivariance constraints
are going to become naturality
constraints.
Uh it's totally fine if you don't
understand what any of these terms are.
The point of this lecture is in part to
teach those fundamental concepts,
hopefully in a in an approachable way.
And what's very critical about these
objects, categories, functors, and
naturality, is they will give us more
expressive power. We'll be able to model
things that are not as constrained as
they would be in a group. So, for
example, transformations will no longer
need to compose all the time.
And this, as a result, will allow us to
more closely model what are the
transformations we want to be resistant
to. And as a result, we might be able to
build neural networks that are better
aligned to the problem that we want to
solve.
Now, one thing that I want to stress on
you, it's very important, is that some
people in the area, especially, might
find category theory to be a bit
unapproachable, almost a bit like uh
uh you know, dealing with uh
unexpected dragons. Here in the corner,
I've asked a version of DALL-E mini to
synthesize uh
uh a picture of a dragon doing category
theory, and I think it did it fairly
accurately.
Um and that is I think primarily because
many of the introduction material you
might find on category theory online is
geared towards mathematicians. If you
don't come from a mathematics
background, I would not recommend you
start learning category theory in this
way, simply because it assumes you know
a lot of standard mathematical
knowledge, which it then uses for
analogies. There exist many
uh very, very good introductions to
category theory, which are in turn
geared towards computer scientists and
even machine learners.
And I would highly recommend, when you
if you start your exploration inside
this field, to always be mindful of uh
who that particular content is
targeting, and basically not to get lost
in the in the dragons.
Uh one of the reasons, though, uh
speaking of this uh older literature,
which is geared towards mathematicians,
one of the reasons why we find it quite
important to talk about category theory
is also that historically,
uh it has always been recognized as a
natural extension of everything that
we've been doing so far. So, if as you
probably remember, especially from
Michael's lectures,
um
the foundation behind what we're doing
here is the Erlangen program of Felix
Klein. Now, if you look at the paper on
general theory of natural equivalences,
which is the first paper to introduce
category theory concepts in 1945 from
Eilenberg and Mac Lane,
you can see this passage inside that
paper,
uh which says that
basically their ideas for category
theory can be seen as a more or less
direct continuation of Klein's Erlangen
program. So, uh the founders of category
theory basically say that their entire
field is based on the ideas of Felix
Klein. And as a result, probably it will
be a natural next step for us to study
as we seek to build uh more general
classes of architectures.
But once again, I would not actually
recommend that you start your journey in
category theory by reading this paper,
unless you have some prerequisite
mathematical knowledge.
So,
uh let's try to demystify what is a
category,
so that we can start our journey of
manipulating categories and relating
them together.
So, it's actually not that complicated
to define what a category is.
So,
uh
to define a category, you need to
specify something that's called a
universe of objects. Now, there's a good
reason why I'm using the word universe
rather than set of objects, and it will
become clear in a few slides' time why I
have to be careful about how I call this
collection. But you can imagine it as
basically some kind of a collection of
objects.
And once you have those objects, you can
also draw morphisms between them. So, a
morphism is just an arrow that connects
one object to another.
And these morphisms cannot be drawn
arbitrarily, they must satisfy a few
simple properties.
So, for this collection of objects and
morphisms to be a valid category, you
need to satisfy the following. For every
object inside the category, there must
be a unique identity morphism for that
object. So, a morphism that maps that
object to itself, and it's often called
ID for that particular object.
Then, if I have two morphisms that could
compose with each other, so I have a F
that connects A to B, and I have a G
that connects B to C, then there must
exist a morphism that takes me directly
from A to C, which is the composition of
those two.
Uh then,
uh it must hold that if you compose any
morphism with the right identity, you'll
get that morphism back,
as you might expect.
And also, associativity must hold. So,
whenever I have three morphisms, F, G,
and H, that could compose with each
other, it doesn't exactly matter in what
order I choose to do the pairwise
compositions.
So, it's hopefully
a fairly simple collection of rules. And
here in the bottom right corner, you see
one example of how
we typically reason about what's going
on in a category by drawing these kinds
of commutative diagrams, which are
basically to some extent, you can
imagine them as directed graphs, where
um objects are nodes, and the morphisms
are edges.
And here you see there's a morphism F
from A to B, there's a morphism G from B
to C, and that means I must have a
morphism which is their composition that
takes me directly from A to C. And you
can see all the three identities
associated with every object. We won't
always draw these identities, because
there are
uh assuming you're working in a
category, the existence of the identity
is guaranteed. But sometimes, especially
for these introductory examples, it's
useful to highlight them.
And why do we call these diagrams
commutative? Well, basically, it's
because whenever you take any particular
pair of objects,
and you look at any path from one to the
other inside a diagram like this,
this path yields the same function. So,
I can choose to go from A to C by going
first F to B and then G to C, or I can
go straight from A to C by following the
composition arrow, the commutative
diagram property says that these two
paths are exactly the same function,
which is the composition G and F. Okay?
So, this is the main concept of uh of
category theory. I hope, like even
though material in category theory
quickly gets complicated, I hope that at
least these basic definitions uh are
basically sensible, and you can kind of
keep them in the back of your minds as
we go along.
Okay.
Now,
there are few important observations we
need to make looking at this collection
of definitions. The first important
observation is that a category indeed
generalizes a group. So, if you look at
the axioms for a category and you
compare them with axioms for a group,
you'll see, okay, I have identities
still, but now I don't have just one
identity for the whole group, I have a
separate identity for every single
object. This is very important.
And also,
I am not at all required in these axioms
to have an inverse. So, if I have a
morphism F that takes me from A to B,
there's nothing inside these rules that
tells me I must have a morphism that
goes back from B to A that is its
inverse. That does not have to hold.
Okay? So, we're already relaxing the
group constraints. And also, quite
obviously, uh from the constraint of I
can only have a composition when the F
and G are composable. So, basically, the
end point of F must equal the start
point of G for me to be able to compose
them together. Uh and this means uh that
in most categories, you won't be able to
compose all pairs of morphisms, simply
because their end points and start
points will not match. So, we've already
created an object that is more general
than a group, so that's a good start.
Although, it still satisfies very
important regularity constraints, such
as associativity and the existence of
identities.
But, one thing that's very critical to
to understand is that when you talk
about things in a categorical
perspective, you are literally just
looking at a collection of objects,
okay? So, when you talk about proofs in
a categorical context and the
derivations in a categorical context,
you are usually not allowed to look at
what's inside these nodes, okay? These
nodes, these objects might be very
complicated mathematical structures, but
you're not allowed to look inside them.
You just see them as A. Right? There's
an object A and that's it. I cannot
really see what's going on. We'll see
concrete examples of this soon, but
basically, this is an important thing to
note. The main
uh aspects of category theory that we
are allowed to study are the morphisms,
so the arrows between those objects. And
this is really interesting because it
allows you to focus when you're
analyzing your models just on the
structure of the computations, the
structure of the arrows, and you're not
thinking too much about the details of
what those arrows are doing, okay? And
it turns out that when you abstract away
these kinds of details, it is really
excellent as a recipe for you to
discover connections. And people uh who
are category theory practitioners are
using category theory uh to basically
discover and rediscover connections
across all different areas of math,
which you might not be able to relate
normally because they operate on very
different types of objects, but the way
in which they operate turns out to be
very similar because of the same
morphism structure. Um I heard a ping,
so do we have a question on campus wire?
Could you read it out?
Yes, there's a question.
Yeah.
Could you read it to me, please? Cuz I
don't have two screens.
Yes, there's a question. Mhm.
So, does morphism mean mapping?
Uh yeah, you can think of morphisms as
mappings. Yeah.
Uh
I would just not think about morphisms
as functions because they don't have to
be functions, but in many cases that
will be of interest to us, morphisms
will be functions.
Okay.
Like, for now, morphisms are just
arrows, so it's something that connects
one object to another.
Okay. So, now let's like I hope uh that
this abstract view into categories
hasn't been uh too scary, and now we can
actually talk about a very concrete
category to first try to ground all of
these concepts uh in something that
should be familiar to all of us. And
also, There's another question. Uh yes,
uh please go ahead.
So, someone say
you talk about morphisms as arrows. So,
that means they are only applicable in
graphs?
Uh no, this doesn't mean they're only
applicable in graphs uh
because you can think about them as uh
computations or transformations that
take you from one category uh from one
object to another, right?
This does not mean that you work in
graphs. We will see some very exciting
categories, for example, that have only
one object, and just morphisms always
take you from that object back to
itself.
But, I mean, uh if you hold on a bit, I
hope to show you specific examples of uh
how we can use morphisms in different
places.
So, we're going to talk about
uh basically something that everybody
who starts category theory, especially
from the perspective of computer
science, sees more or less as a first
example, and that is the set category,
the category of sets.
So,
what uh one thing that's very important
is that when you talk about a category,
you always always should start by
specifying the details of that category.
So, just make it clear what are going to
be the objects and what are going to be
the morphisms.
Because that is a necessary theoretical
grounding that establishes the the
constraints of the category, and without
them, it's not very clear what is uh the
setting you're working in.
And for the set category,
uh the objects are going to be sets,
and the morphisms are going to be
functions between them.
Now,
here you immediately see the first
example of why when I said when I when
we talked about our collection of
objects, I had to use the word universe,
which is a bit weird, right? Why would
why didn't I say sets?
Well, for those of you who have done
some aspects of set theory, you might
have heard of Russell's paradox, which
uh says uh which asks, "Does a set of
all sets contain itself?" And it's a
very paradoxical question, which
basically means that uh
defining sets of sets is potentially a
bit tricky.
And if I were to say that my category
has all fi uh all sets, and uh
I am also allowed to create sets of
objects, which means I can create sets
of sets, I might run into a problem of
uh of this paradox, okay? And that's why
there is this formal mathematical
concept of a universe, which is you can
think of it basically a collection of uh
of items which avoids these kinds of
paradoxes.
But, it's not critical for for what we
are going to do. So, basically, you can
imagine this category as just a
collection of sets, and morphisms are
functions between them. So, here on the
right-hand side of this uh slide, you
see one particular example of two
objects and a morphism. So, you have
sets A and B, and you have one
particular function F between them,
which is a morphism between them.
Okay? And as you might expect, a
function takes elements of the input
set, and to every element of the input
set attaches an element in the output
set.
Okay.
However,
as I said,
in a category theory perspective, we are
not allowed to look inside these
objects, okay? So, what you will see in
a diagram is actually this thing. You
have A, just an object A, you have B,
just an object B, and you have F, an
arrow connecting the two of them, which
indicates to you that there exists a
function F that maps elements of A to
elements of B. But, you're not allowed
to look at what is A, what is B, or
specifically how F maps parts of A to
parts of B. You're not allowed to look
at that, okay?
And uh I think it's a very good exercise
for you to do afterwards is to show that
if I define my set category in this way,
where objects are sets and morphisms are
functions, that it can be made to
satisfy all of the important axioms of
categories that I showed you a few
slides ago. So, essentially, uh that
you're able to compose these arrows, uh
that uh the order of the so that you
have a associativity in compositions,
and that you have uh a unique identity
for every single uh set. Okay?
Now, you might be asking, and you know,
here I've kind of drawn in faded colors
the actual contents of A and B, so you
can see that in reality underneath,
there's still very rich sets happening
underneath these objects. You might be
wondering, okay, but if you take all
that complexity inside what's in A and
B, and you reduce all of that to just a
node for A and a node for B, doesn't
this drop a lot of data?
And I will now show you, hopefully, a
mind-blowing result
uh that illustrates why this is actually
not quite the case. Like, even though
we're not allowed to look inside our
sets, we can still say many, many things
about what's inside those sets.
So,
we will go through this together. We'll
go through this in a sequence of uh of
uh of exercises.
And specifically, what we're going to
first talk about is the special set
called a one-element set.
Uh sometimes it's called unit, sometimes
it's denoted by these open and closed
parentheses, which uh I have
deliberately used because it relates to
functional programming. So, for any of
you who have done any Haskell or similar
kind of language, you will see this
notation of open closed parentheses to
basically talk about a set with a single
element. Okay?
And now, like, you know, not thinking
about the confines of a category, I'm
just asking you a question, if my
morphisms are functions,
I'm going to take any set A, right? With
any number of elements, and I'm asking
you, what can you tell me about the
functions from any set A to this unit
element set? Like, is there anything
special about these functions?
And since I don't see anyone,
like, actively in Zoom, you can post
your answers in Campuswire, and maybe
you can read out to me what the answers
are.
Hi, Victor.
There is one answer to you now. Mhm.
Answer is
unique. Unique, exactly. So, when you
think of answer Mhm. Everything maps to
one element.
Exactly. Great. So, you're still with
me, and this is exactly what I wanted
you to say. So, there actually exists
exactly one morphism from a set A to the
unit set. Okay? And that is exactly the
function that maps every single element
of A to that particular node, right?
And actually, this property that every
single set in my category has exactly
one morphism to the unit set uniquely
defines the unit set up to isomorphism.
So, every single set with one element
will have exactly the same property, but
only the sets with one element will have
this special property. Okay? And when
you look at what this looks like
categorically,
this is a property that says, no matter
what set A I choose, there will be
exactly one arrow from that set to the
unit set. Okay? This allows me to just
look at the arrows and uniquely
identify, up to isomorphism, the unit
set. Okay? And from a category theory
perspective,
uh this thing is actually called a
terminal object. So, if you have an
object in your category such that every
other object points to it by exactly one
arrow, then it's called a terminal
object. And in the case of the set
category, the single element set is
terminal object, and this allows us to
uniquely identify it. So, we can always,
without any doubt, identify which object
is a set with one element. But now,
we're in a pretty magnificent situation,
because if we know what object has a
single element set inside it,
then we can talk about morphisms from
that set to any other set B. So, here I
have now my unit set that I just
discovered on the left-hand side, and I
want to talk about the morphisms from it
to any other set B. So, who could tell
me what are the morphisms from the unit
to B?
Once again, please write your answers on
Campuswire.
Hi, Victor. I think this time they need
your help.
Okay, fair enough.
So,
we start from this one element that is
inside unit, and what does a function do
from that element to a different set B?
Well,
you just need to choose some element of
B to map units to, right?
So, this is the collection of morphisms
from unit to B. I hope that makes sense.
So, every single function from unit to B
isolates one particular element of B,
and that's why sometimes, especially in
functional programming languages, we
call these morphisms the constants on B.
Okay? You get one morphism per element
of B, right? I hope this makes sense.
So, in this case, where B has six
elements, and I numbered them from one
to six just for convenience, uh you have
a separate morphism G1, G2, G3, and so
on that isolates every single element of
B. And the number of morphisms you have
is, as you can tell, probably equal to
the number of elements that you have
inside B. So, I hope this answers uh the
question.
Please write on Campuswire if this
doesn't make sense. But, what's really
fantastic about this,
like, if you look at now the arrows
going from the unit to any particular
set B,
is that every single morphism here from
the unit to B isolates one element of B,
one unique element of B. And as a
result, taking all these six morphisms
together, I can tell you exactly what
the elements of B are, up to
isomorphism, right? So, the fact that
there exist six arrows taking me from
unit to B immediately tells me that B
has the same structure as the set 1 2 3
4 5 6. Okay?
So, I must stress on you how how epic
this result actually is, right? Because
we never looked at what's inside any of
these sets when we drew these arrows,
right? We just looked at the properties
of the arrows, the structure of the
arrows. And from the structure of the
arrows alone, we were able to
reconstruct the elements of any set in
our category, up to isomorphism, right?
So, I've been able to tell you
everything about what's inside an object
B,
even though I never actually had to look
at what's inside the object B. I just
had to tell, this is the unit, and now
the unit has six arrows to that
particular object.
Was there a question?
Yes, there is one question. Mhm.
So, under which conditions do we get
each element G1, G2, etc.?
I mean, there are there are no
particular additional conditions,
really. So, under the constraints of the
set category,
we shown how we're able to identify the
single element set,
and then we know that every unique arrow
from that set to another set tells you
one particular element of that set. So,
for all intents and purposes, you can
think of the collection of morphisms
from unit to B as the set of objects
inside B.
I hope this answers the question.
Um
Okay. So,
the reason why I think this result is
quite quite awesome is because you're
now have this framework where you're not
concerning yourself with what's inside
the objects, like, what's the data
you're doing computation over,
you can just look at the patterns of
computations, so, basically, the arrows
between these objects that transform
them,
and
you're able to focus on this to be able
to detect patterns across different
areas of math
without drastically losing information,
really. Like, I've been able to tell
you, up to isomorphism, what is all the
elements inside a particular set just by
looking at the arrows.
And that's, in my opinion, pretty cool.
And it will be quite helpful when we
reason about how all this applies to
deep learning.
Now, one thing that's very important for
you to keep in your minds is that all
the results we get from category theory,
such as this great result about you can
reconstruct everything inside the set
category,
it's all made under the assumption of
what category you're working in. So,
often a very important first step when
you do any categorical derivation is to
be very clear and up-front about what's
the category you're working in. And just
because you found a result in one
category, that does not mean that they
must transfer to another category. And
just as an exercise, I think could be
quite insightful, if you look at the
category of relations, which we often
call Rel. So, your objects are still
sets, but your morphisms now don't have
to be functions, they can be relations.
So, uh relations are a strictly relaxed
notion of a function where, for example,
one object can be related to many other
objects in the other set, or some
objects even do not need to be related
to any other objects, and so on.
And if you now you make an arrow from
set A to set B for a relation between
them,
what would be the terminal object inside
this category? I think it's a very
important and insightful question, and
then, following up from there, can we
even do this trickery of discovering a
single element set if our morphisms are
relations rather than functions. So,
have a thought about this. I think it's
a very instructive exercise.
And it could be also quite relevant if
you choose to take a categorical
question in the exam, for example.
Okay.
Now,
sorry, was there a question?
Yes, there is one question.
What is the meaning of real? R E L.
Yeah, so that's that is a category where
objects are sets and morphisms are
relations. They're no longer functions.
So, when we looked at set
morphisms were functions. Now, in Rel,
morphisms become relations.
And this means they're more relaxed,
less restricted than functions. And now
the question is, do you have a terminal
object inside this category? And if so,
what is its structure?
Okay.
So, now we have the question of because
I said this notion of a category should
generalize a group.
So, let's think about what would a group
look like inside a categorical realm.
Well, what are the things that
categories relaxed that groups had very
strict? First, you did not have an
identity for every single object, right?
All identities had to be the same.
Then, you had to be able to take any
pair of transformations, which in the
context of categories are morphisms. So,
you need to take any pair of morphisms
and make them able to compose with one
another.
And also,
all of our group transformations had an
inverse. So, all morphisms also need to
have an inverse. Okay. And it turns out
that looking at these properties will
pretty much directly tell us what
a group looks like in this category
scenario.
So, basically, if you look at the first
two prescriptions, then it's a fun
exercise to convince yourselves why this
is the case.
But basically,
if you need all of your identities to be
equal, and remember I defined an
identity for every object separately,
right?
And you need to make all pairs of
morphisms composable. So, basically, the
end point of every morphism must equal
the start point of every other morphism.
I hope you can fairly quickly come to
the conclusion that this means that a
category corresponding to a group must
have exactly one object.
This object G here, okay?
And
the fact that you say your category
corresponding to a group only has one
object immediately gives you the first
two properties, right? Because there
will be exactly one identity, the
identity of G.
So, you've satisfied the fact that
there's a unique identity
transformation.
And also, because every morphism will go
from G back to itself, that means you'll
be able to compose it with any other
morphism, which also takes G back to
itself. Okay?
So,
uh
after the lecture, or if it immediately
strikes alarm bells, let me know. But
basically, you should always you should
take a moment to convince yourself that
if all identities need to be the same
and all pairs of morphisms need to
compose, I can only satisfy this if my
category has exactly one object.
Okay?
Now, of course, it might sound a bit
restrictive, right? If I have a category
with only one object. But in reality,
there's still a lot of very rich
structure inside these arrows that I can
use to study my computation, right?
And specifically, we still have the
third condition that every morphism
needs to have an inverse. So, if you
remember in the previous picture, I had
some identity, I had function F, sorry,
morphism F, a morphism G, composition of
the two.
Uh now, I need to make sure also all of
the inverses of these morphisms are also
present.
And it turns out in order to recover
inverses, you need some condition on the
morphisms, which would sort of
generalize a bijection in in function in
function terms.
Specifically, uh we call a morphism F,
which takes A to B, to be an isomorphism
if there exists a morphism G that will
take me back
from B to A such that no matter how I
compose the two, I'll get the respective
identity, right? So, in some sense, we
can think of G and F as inverses of each
other. But in a categorical setting,
this is already a bit more general than
having invertible functions because, as
you can see, the order in which you
compose the inverses gives you a
different identity. Of course, in the
context of groups, we have exactly one
object, and as a result, these two
identities will be the same, as we would
expect. But just to say, in general
categories with more than one object,
these inverses are not quite inverses.
And once we have a notion of inverses,
we can now finally complete our
definition of what a group is inside a
category perspective. So, a group is a
category that has a single object G.
And all the morphisms from G to itself
are isomorphisms.
And I hope this illustrates to you just
how much of a special case groups are,
right? It's a very specific category
with exactly one element and with a very
harsh condition on the arrows. And I
hope this tells you how if I'm allowed
to build more generic categories, which
aren't having the structure of this
group, uh that basically,
uh you know, you're able to represent
far richer classes of computation in
this way.
And I think it's also a good exercise
for you to look at afterwards uh to show
that if I take a composition of two
arrows in the setting where I have
inverses,
and take the inverse of that
composition, it is the same as inverting
the corresponding morphisms and then
composing them in the other direction.
And it's good to try to prove this using
only the definitions of categories I've
given you so far.
Okay.
Uh so, was there a question?
Yes, there is question. Mhm.
Uh the question is, so, a group is a
group in the set of functions containing
one category, this is the question. Or
this is only referring to this
particular case.
Right. So, what uh what I just showed
you is that
groups
have to be in a categorical context
context, groups have to be a category
with one object, exactly one object. And
then the interesting symmetry
transformations inside those groups are
morphisms that take that object back to
itself, which sort of makes sense,
right? Because we talked about
symmetries as transformations that leave
an object unchanged. So, it makes sense
to have one object, and then every
morphism takes you back from that object
back to itself, right? Because it's
semantically the same thing.
Um I hope this answers the question. Uh
was there another one?
Yes, another question. Yeah. The
condition for the condition for a group
is that there exist exactly one inverse.
If in our formulation of groups using
category theory, we have two identities,
how this how how is that still a group?
But you don't have two identities. This
is the key thing, right? Because you
have a category of exactly one element,
right?
And therefore, there exists exactly one
identity.
So, in this particular case, if I go
back to the definition of what an
inverse is in a category context, here
both G and F will have to take G back to
itself, G the group object, right? And
as a result, you'll always get IDG as a
result. So, in this particular case, you
don't have a problem because there is
exactly one identity. The moment you put
more than one object, you no longer have
a group, and your inverses are not
traditional inverses anymore.
Okay.
So,
I hope that
this exposition of what a category is
abstractly, as you know, a collection of
objects and arrows that satisfy some
simple properties, and then the fact we
were able to derive sets and groups
inside this framework, and basically
showing how groups are a very special
case of what you can do with these
interesting
arrow collections,
uh it already shows you that there is
some power in category theory to explain
things that group theory wasn't able to
explain. Okay?
But
I still haven't shown you the magic
hammer, right? The part where category
theory really starts to become powerful.
And actually, category theory gets some
of its most powerful results not within
a single category, where it can still
explain a lot of interesting stuff, but
when you take multiple categories and
you let them interact with one another.
And
very often in category theory, you're
really just trying to redefine a concept
you already knew and loved from before,
and try to make it fit with within the
category framework, right? So, when we
talked about isomorphisms, we were
really trying to generalize the notion
of function functions that have
inverses, right?
Uh and the same way we think about
functions between sets, when we talk
about interactions between categories,
we can define a related notion of a
functor. Okay?
Now, what's special about functors is
that
they don't just act on objects, they
also act on morphisms. So,
to be formal about this, if I have two
categories C and D,
I can invent a functor capital F that
takes C to D. And what does it do?
It maps both the objects in C to objects
in D, but also the morphisms in C to
morphisms in D.
And you cannot just do this in an
arbitrary way. A functor must preserve
structure, or well, respect structure
inside the the input category. And what
does this mean? If I take my functor and
I apply it to an identity of some
object, then the morphism I get inside
the other category must be the identity
morphism for the object where that A
gets mapped to. Okay? So, F of the
identity of A is the same as the
identity of F of A.
And secondly, the composition structure
must be respected as well. So, if I take
any composition of functions F and G,
and I transform it into the other
category using the functor,
it is the same as if I first transform
the individual morphisms using the
functor and then compose them in
category D. Okay? So, it's a fairly
simple collection of just two rules, but
using those two rules, you can basically
talk about very intricate relationships
between categories.
And just to demonstrate this, so here is
the familiar picture I showed you before
of a category with three elements and
morphisms F and G that compose to get F
and G together, and every single object
A, B, and C has an identity.
So, if I now build a functor from that
category into another category,
what I'm really saying is, you see here
the functor as the dashed arrow F, it
maps the three objects I have to
different objects inside a different
category, so F of A, F of B, F of C.
Um
By the way, these don't have to be
distinct, they could also map to the
same objects. But what is important is
that the structure that was there in the
first category must be present when you
map it with functor to the second
category. Okay? So, you see exactly the
same structure of the diagram
that we had on the left-hand side, which
was in category C, exactly the same
structure must exist inside category D.
And it's fun to like ponder
this structure that the functor
preserves, but maybe a kind of a better
way to think about it is that whenever
you have a good analogy between two
concepts,
it's basically something that you can
represent nicely using a functor, right?
It's basically saying, I have these two
kinds of computations in these two
different categories, but they look
basically the same. And my functor tells
me how to map computations in one
category to computations in another.
Okay?
So, I hope uh
like
the diagram itself might be complicated,
but in reality, it's really just some
kind of pattern you see in category C
gets mapped to very similar kinds of
patterns in category D.
I hope I hope this I hope this makes
sense. And by the way, this diagram is
commutative, so any pair of paths you
take from any object to any other object
should result in exactly the same
morphism.
Okay.
So,
I hope this makes sense.
And now, let's talk about how this
relates to geometric deep learning,
right? Because in order to be able to
build strong geometric deep learning
models, we needed to have useful
equivariant constraints, right?
And to get equivariant constraints, we
needed additionally the concept of a
group representation. Here I have just
to as a reminder what a group
representation is, it's this mapping row
that takes individual elements in my
group and gives me a unique n by n real
matrix that take has the same effect as
the group action, but inside the domain
of linear algebra, which is very helpful
because in deep learning, we really just
care about linear algebra.
And it turns out, as you might expect,
we can also generalize this concept of a
group representation to categories,
but we have to use functors to make that
possible because we need to map between
abstract group elements and
transformations of of real vectors. Was
there a question?
Yes.
The question is, are we looking at the
two categories as nodes in a graph?
You could think about categories even
just as nodes in a graph, and at this
point, you talk about the category of
all categories, where things get a bit
wacky.
But
you can also think about each category
having its own graph with its own nodes
and edges, and then a functor maps from
nodes of one to nodes of the other.
But yes, you could look at you could
look at it in that context as well.
Now, specifically,
uh since we want our functor to produce
linear operators, right? So, we go from
what was inside the group, which is an
abstract object, to an explicit matrix
we can multiply with to perform the
group action, we actually need to have a
functor,
which is now row, that maps our
single-element category G, which
represents the group, to the category of
vector spaces, which we call Vect. Now,
once again, I have a new category.
Whenever I have a new category, I need
to tell you what are the objects and
what are the morphisms.
So, Vect, in particular, is a category
of vector spaces, which means its
objects are sets of vectors,
and those vectors need to support the
usual axioms for a vector space. So, you
must be able to add them together, you
need to multiply with scalars, it needs
to be associative, distributive, and all
those standard standard rules.
So, those are objects. Like, one object
in Vect is an entire collection of
vectors that satisfies these operations.
And the morphisms between these spaces
are linear transformations.
So, think of them basically as matrices
you can multiply with these vectors, if
they're discrete at least, to map from
one space to another. So, say a
K-dimensional real space to a
L-dimensional real space. If you have a
matrix that multiplies R to the K to R
to the L, then that will be a morphism
between those two between those two
objects.
So, what does a functor from a group to
the vector spaces tell you? Well, uh
it tells you how the morphisms in G, so
the group operations, group symmetries,
map to specific linear transformations.
And because G has only one object, from
a point of view of objects, this functor
row basically tells you how these how
this group symmetries act on one
particular vector space, right? And
also, what it implies is that you can
have separate functors to describe how a
group acts on different vector spaces.
So, this is what it looks like very
concretely in the concept of a
permutation group of three elements.
So, hopefully, this should now make
reasonable amounts of sense after we
read the rediscovered how groups fit
within the context of categories.
So, if you take a three-element
permutation group, its morphisms, so
it's a category with a single object,
and its morphisms will be all
permutations of three elements, right?
And now you take a functor which maps
that to a vector space. Well,
specifically, because there's only one
object, it maps to a particular vector
space V, and inside that object, you
also need to map all the morphisms to
respect the structure, and as you might
expect, every single functorial mapping
of a permutation on the left-hand side
gives you a permutation matrix on the
right-hand side. So, something you can
multiply V with to permute the elements
of your vectors. Okay?
So, I hope this kind of makes sense how
we can talk about group representations
in the context of categories. It is a
functor from a group, which is a
single-element category, mapping to
mapping to a particular vector space,
and then mapping all the group
morphisms, group transformations, to a
specific matrix representation of that
particular group action.
I hope this makes sense. If there are
any questions, please feel free to ask
them, and we can we can go through them.
Um I will, in the meantime, proceed to
the next slide.
So, once we have this idea of using a
functor to talk about group
representations, we can now generalize
what it means for a function or a neural
network to be equivariant. And if you
remember, all of this course was
basically about giving equivariant
constraints and then using them to build
all of geometric deep learning, right?
All of neural networks, basically.
So, to talk about what this looks like
in the context of categories, I'm going
to recall this diagram which Taco showed
you in a previous lecture that he gave.
I just slightly renamed some of the
things to make it more aligned with what
we're what the notation is that I'm
using.
But basically, you know, we have these
vector spaces V and V prime. So, for
example, V can be a K-dimensional real
vector space.
And our neural network layer is a linear
function that maps one vector space to
another, so it's a morphism. Like, our
neural network F is a morphism in the
category of
of vector spaces. We'll get to that in a
second.
And then we have a symmetry group we
would want this a function F to be
resistant to, so we have symmetry group
elements G, and we can create its
representations, so say specific
permutation matrices if G is a group of
permutations,
uh row V and row V prime, which tells
you how
uh this symmetry group acts inside the
vector spaces V and V prime.
And then,
in general, we say that a function F is
G-equivariant if we have this uh
commutative diagram, right? Where you
can either first apply the function and
then apply the symmetry transformation
or first apply the symmetry
transformation and then the function and
you'll get exactly the same outcome. So,
this is the main condition that we want
uh that we want to talk about, right?
And uh
I hope you can see how all of these
different uh concepts map quite neatly
to categories, because you can think of
these vector spaces V and V prime as
just objects in the Vect category,
cuz they're different vector spaces.
And your linear functions, your neural
network layers that take V to V prime
are morphisms inside the vector
category, right? Because they take one
vector space to a different vector
space.
And a symmetry group, as we discussed
previously, is a category G with a
single object, and its symmetries are
morphisms from G back to itself.
And our representations that map a
symmetry group operation uh
to a uh morphism in Vect are just
functors, right? So, they're a functor
that takes a group uh repre- a group
category and maps it to a particular
object inside the Vect category.
And they map also the objects uh the
object G to a particular vector space V,
and then they map every morphism G to G
to a corresponding matrix representation
V to V, which, as we know, is a morphism
inside the category of vector spaces.
So, now the constraint of equivariance
tells us that if we have a that we need
to have a morphism that somehow connects
these two functors, right? We have row V
and row V prime,
and our morphism F needs to somehow
connect them. And this con- connection
constraint in category theory is called
a natural transformation, and it's one
of the most powerful concepts in
category theory. In fact, uh the
founders of category theory invented
functors just so they would be able to
talk about the naturality constraint.
And in essence, as I said, it's a
relationship between two functors. So,
let's take two functors F and G that
both map category C to category D.
And now a natural transformation eta
between them operates as follows.
For every object inside category C, we
have a special morphism eta A that maps
uh F of A to G of A, so basically the
two different outcomes of applying these
two functors. And specifically, these
etas need to commute with the two
functors like in the condition you see
below you. I'll show you this
pictorially, but it's a very nice kind
of commutative square.
So,
what is this constraint, right? If you
look at it pictorially. So, at the
bottom here you have A and B, which are
linked together by morphism F inside an
original category. And now I have two
functors, F and G, which will map my
objects and they will also map my arrow,
okay? So, I have F of A, F of B, G of A,
G of B, and I also have F of F mapping A
to B in the F space, and G of F, which
maps A to B in the G space, right?
And
you know,
uh what is then a natural
transformation? Well, it's a unique
arrow from every single object to its
its uh realization in a different
functor, such that this diagram
commutes. So, you have this naturality
square between F of A, F of B, G of A,
and G of B.
And uh
one thing that's really fundamental
about this is that, as you can see, we
are defining a different morphism for
every single object. Eta A and eta B
might be different.
And if you remember in basic
equivariance, these two arrows had to
actually look the same. They had to be
exactly the same function, right? And
since we will use these morphisms as a
way to eventually represent neural
network layers, what does it mean? Using
this uh using this naturality square, we
might come up with neural networks that
have different weights, so different
functions, depending on which inputs
they get. And this is very different to
the kinds of models we built before,
where this function, this morphism had
to be the same in every single object.
So, maybe it's just useful to show how
the normal group equivariance is a
special case of this. So, here I've
redrawn this diagram for the case where
I just have a single object category, so
G, which is our group, and I have a
particular group symmetry G that I want
to get a representation from. So, this
is the lowercase G, which maps uh a
single element back to itself. And as we
discussed, we have two different
functors, row V and row V prime, that uh
map uh G to different vector spaces and
also map this symmetry transformation
into different uh morphisms between
them.
And then, our equivariance constraint is
that our neural network F needs to be a
natural transformation between them, so
it needs to map the spaces V and V prime
in a way that this diagram will commute,
so it doesn't matter in what order you
choose to compose the arrows.
And you can hopefully see how this is a
special case of what I showed you on the
previous slide, right? So, now you can
compose uh just a unique function F and
uh use it everywhere, because these
spaces V and V prime are always the
same. It is a consequence of the fact
that G is a single-object category. Uh
so, you can see how it's a special case
of what I showed you before, where you
might have a different transformation in
every single element, but the square is
still closed.
Okay?
And now I will just briefly tell you how
you can apply this concept of naturality
to graph neural networks.
So, previously we defined graph neural
networks or GNNs using permutation
equivariance, and as we usually had, it
is the same function F applied to every
single graph. But in principle, there is
nothing wrong with having different
functions for different graphs. You just
have to be careful about isomorphism
structures, right? And this lines up
really nicely with natural
transformations. And now I'll just
quickly talk to you about the category
that we can use to represent graphs and
the functors that we can use to
represent data on graphs, and then the
naturality condition will let us define
a graph neural network that doesn't have
the same parameters for every single
graph.
So, specifically,
there are many ways to think about a
category where objects are graphs, but
uh one thing that will help us a lot in
terms of identifying different elements
together is to use their adjacency
matrices. Now, it's not the only way to
look at them, it's just the most
convenient way for us. So, the objects
in this category are adjacency matrices,
and the morphisms are isomorphisms, so
permutations that permute rows and
columns. And by the way, this also means
that they must be invertible cuz I can
always apply the inverse permutation to
get back where I came from.
So,
as mentioned, we have objects, which are
these matrices. Here I've just drawn the
graph on the left-hand side with the
numbers corresponding to different rows
and columns in this matrix, so you can
kind of orient yourself with what this
graph looks like.
And now, the morphisms in my category of
graphs are going to take me from one
adjacency matrix to another, which is a
result of of permuting the individual
node IDs. So, here, for example, I've
done a permutation that swaps nodes one
and two, and it accordingly permutes the
adjacency matrix. So, this is now an
isomorphism
uh of these two adjacency matrices, uh
but it's a way of telling me that these
two graph structures are actually
fundamentally related and I should
process them in the same way.
However, some of these permutations are
special,
right? If I instead choose to permute uh
by swapping objects uh sorry, nodes two
and four, I'll actually, you can
convince yourselves that I'll actually
get the same adjacency matrix as the one
I started from. And these isomorphisms
are actually special, we call them
automorphisms, because they will
actually give you, even though it's a
well-defined permutation operation, it
will leave you with exactly the same
structure as the one you started from,
okay?
So, there's a very clear distinction, so
not all isomorphisms are made equal when
you look at things from the perspective
of adjacency matrices.
And in fact, this structure, where you
have different adjacency matrices, and
every one of them, if you can permute to
get from one to the other, has a
isomorphism, so both uh a morphism and
its inverse, so to speak, going from one
to the other, and then also there's
automorphisms that map uh each
uh object back to itself, so each
adjacency matrix back to itself, and
obviously there's a identity
uh permutation, which is trivially an
automorphism. Uh you end up with a
category that looks something like this.
So, the structure looks a bit like this.
If you've ever seen equivalence classes
in mathematics, it's basically something
like this. So, you have collections of
objects that are all tightly related to
one another. And in fact, you can think
about this as basically a collection of
mini groups.
And just for this reason, uh categories
that only have isomorphisms as their
morphisms are known as groupoids. So,
they generalize groups to a category
that might have more than one object,
but the arrows between them are still
isomorphisms, so you can still very
tightly relate the different objects to
one another.
So, note how this already gives us more
processing power in terms of
generalization or expressivity as
opposed to using a simple group of
permutations, which would only have one
object, right? Now we have many objects,
one for every single adjacency matrix we
might want to build.
And uh now we can just take functors
that map our groupoids to the vector
spaces to represent our uh you know,
group actions groupoid actions, so to
speak.
And the specific way in which uh a
morphism, which as we discussed is a
permutation,
uh acts inside that vector space depends
on what kinds of features you have uh in
your graph. So, if you have features
over the entire graph like these
scalars, then the permutation operation
does nothing to it in the vector space.
If you have node features, then it
permutes the node features appropriately
by multiplying with P. If you have edge
features over pairs of nodes, then it
applies the same permutation to the rows
and the columns. And in all of these
cases, you can have multiple features by
just extending another axis, but it's
not that axis is not affected by the
permutations.
And now, once you have these objects,
morphisms, and functors, you can derive
a naturality condition for every single
isomorphism. And the specific
constraints you get are twofold. Every
automorphism will tell you which message
functions need to be shared, so which
pairs of nodes must communicate in the
same way. And then all isomorphic graphs
need to share all these message
functions between them. So, what's the
main novelty here? Basically, with
standard vanilla GNNs, you had to use
the same message function for every
single edge. Now, a different edge can
use a different message function as long
as the automorphisms are respected. And
this obviously makes your graph neural
network more powerful, right?
Specifically, for the graph that I
showed you before as an example, you can
have three distinct message passing
mechanisms that respect the fact that
two and four are related by an
automorphism, so they always need to
communicate with the same with the same
message. Then one can use a separate
message to communicate with the two of
them, and then a separate message to
communicate with three, which is kind of
unrelated directly to the two and four.
So, this makes you have rather than
having just one message function, which
is a which is which is what a standard
graph neural network would have, you
would have three of them, red, blue, and
green applied to different edges.
And it's a good question why can we not
use more than three, which I'll leave
for you as an exercise.
And now, no matter how I choose to
permute the nodes in my graph, I have
another constraint of the isomorphisms
that these message functions need to be
exactly the same no matter how I choose
to permute my nodes.
Now, there's a few issues with this,
like even though this concept of not
having to use the same message function
everywhere can be remarkably powerful.
In this basic way I've presented it to
you, it is a bit overpowered because you
need to specify for every single
automorphism class these explicit
constraints, and graphs which are not
isomorphic can have completely different
parameters. And as a result, you don't
really scale to large graphs, you can
never generalize to unseen graphs
because unseen graph structures you will
never have any training data to train
their message functions. And also, every
set of isomorphic input graphs has their
own parameters. So, this global idea of
a natural graph network can then be
specialized to a local natural graph
network, which I will not have time to
talk about in this lecture, but the
general idea is rather than looking at
the whole graph, you look at
neighborhoods of every node and edge as
a separate subgraph, and then think
about the isomorphisms of that subgraph
and the constraints induced by them
using similar ideas that we just
discussed. And it's actually possible
when you talk about it in a local manner
to satisfy these naturality constraints
elegantly without explicitly having to
solve for them. And if you want more
details, I invite you to check out the
natural graph networks from uh Pim De
Haan and the Taco and Max Welling uh for
more details.
So,
I hope this kind of quick uh and
overview excursion shows you how we can
use this idea of generalizing a group to
a more complicated object or an object
with more interesting structures called
a category, uh and how using the
categorical observation, we could define
graph neural networks which uh do not
have the same message function
everywhere, but still respect the
isomorphism structure of graphs. So,
this is a blueprint we can use to build
more powerful models beyond group
theory.
Yeah, it is still a relatively niche
area, but it is becoming more and more
prevalent over the previous years in
research, so we can expect that it's a
very important skill to try to master
for the future. So, now we've covered
the table of key GDL architectures.
We've discussed how we can use the
categories and category theory to expand
it beyond group theoretic prescriptions.
And I showed you one quick example of
how you can build a graph neural network
that is correct, but doesn't have
explicit full permutation equivariance,
so you can actually unshare some of the
parameters across the graph.
And the final lecture that Michael will
give uh in a bit today will then show
how you can take all of these ideas from
geometric deep learning and powerfully
apply them in various impactful
applications, also some outlook on how
the area will develop. And then uh
tomorrow you will have uh a very special
final guest lecture from Russ Bates from
the AlphaFold team that shows you how
DeepMind used some of these ideas in
their protein folding model that won the
cover of Nature.
So, this is it for me. It's the last
time I'm lecturing for you in the
context of this course. I hope you have
enjoyed the three lectures I've given
you and the whole course in general, and
we're always happy and open to receive
any feedback or any questions you might
have. Thank you so much. You've been a
fantastic audience.